what are the common mistakes that you
see people making that are easily
avoidable like if you have a minute just
be like please stop doing this thing
that I always see people doing over
training which everybody over trains
like I mean I understand if you are
trying to be a professional and can get
there like you got to put the work in
but if if you're over trained for what
you all the other stuff you have in your
lifestyle you're gonna hit the race
course yeah unprepared and not being
able to access the work you've done get
a coach or get on a program find some
people around you that you can train
with and share the enthusiasm enjoyment
with talk about it with your family you
know don't make those plans by yourself
make them make them as a family put more
energy into some of the other details
you know get a proper bike fit or you
know learn about nutrition things like
that like make yourself as sufficient as
possible so your success can come from
something else other than just training
20 to 25 hours a week yeah